[Music]
hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd and
i don't think i smelled that much
today we're talking about armpit stink
you might have seen a lot of natural
deodorants on the market and you might
have been wondering
do you really need to switch is there
any truth to the idea that aluminium is
bad for you
this is the video for you if you like
noting out about the science behind
beauty products click the like the
subscribe and click the notification
bell so you don't miss any videos
[Music]
aluminium compounds are found in lots of
antiperspirant products and the main
reason they're in there is to
stop you from sweating as much and cut
down on body odor these are ingredients
like aluminium chlorohydrate these
interact with water and they form a plug
in your sweat gland
and so that stops the sweat from coming
out this plug comes out naturally later
when your skin cells shed and this is
what keeps your armpits dry with body
odor there are two main ingredients that
combine to make you stink
odor forming chemicals or odor
precursors that are found in some types
of sweat
and the right kind of bacteria mostly
curing bacteria
and also staphylococci basically larger
molecules can't evaporate as easily so
they can't make it to your nose where
you can smell it
in fresh sweat the odor molecules are
part of a larger molecule
they need the bacteria to come along and
chop off the odor molecule to free it
and then it can drift
off into your nose and make you stink so
without the bacteria the sweat won't
smell and without the sweat the bacteria
has nothing to chop up
and cause stank the aluminium based
plugs block the sweat and so there's
less fuel for the bacteria to
turn into odor it also makes your
armpits less damp and so it's a less
friendly environment for bacteria to sit
around and poop out stink
so overall these aluminium salts are a
super effective way of cutting down on
stink
but like with any other unnatural
sounding ingredient there's been a lot
of fear-mongering around aluminium
[Music]
i think this is the scariest claim that
aluminium is linked to breast cancer
but pretty much all reputable sources
says there's no link
so the canadian cancer society says
there is no evidence that the use of
antiperspirants
increases your risk for breast cancer
there is no link between aluminium and
breast cancer risk
the american cancer society says there
are no strong epidemiologic studies in
the medical literature that link breast
cancer risk
and antiperspirant use and very little
scientific evidence to support this
claim
cancer research uk says there is no good
evidence that aluminium in deodorants
could increase the risk of cancer in
animals or humans
the national cancer institute says no
scientific evidence links the use of
these products to the development of
breast cancer
no studies to date have confirmed any
substantial adverse effects of aluminium
that could contribute to increased
breast cancer risks
in late 2019 the european commission's
scientific committee on consumer safety
re-evaluated aluminium antiperspirants
and again they concluded that they were
safe in the amounts used in cosmetics
so that's around six percent in
non-spray antiperspirants and ten
percent in spray antiperspirants
a number of scientific reviews over the
years have found that there's no clear
evidence that using
aluminium antiperspirants increases the
risk of breast cancer
the 2008 review made a very bold
statement
after analysis of the available
literature on the subject no scientific
evidence to support the hypothesis was
identified
and no validated hypothesis appears
likely to open the way to interesting
avenues of research
so if you've ever interacted with
scientists you'll know that it takes a
lot for a scientist to say there is
absolutely nothing
and even more to make a scientist say
that there is no point in further
researching a topic
so where did this myth come from and why
does it keep persisting if you've been
following any sort of ingredient fear
mongering in beauty or
anywhere else you'll know that this is
usually how it goes
an in vitro study suggests a possible
link the conditions in the in vitro
study
didn't really reflect the reality of how
that ingredients used
people ran with it anyway large-scale
population studies didn't find a link
but no one cares anymore because
everyone is already freaking out
so here's the evidence for aluminium
being linked to breast cancer
firstly breast cancer tumors are usually
found near the armpit
breast cancer tumors are usually found
in the upper outer quadrant of the
breast
that's right next to the armpit and so
people started wondering
if some of the so-called unnatural
things we used in our armpits could be
linked
a more likely explanation that most
medical people point out is that there's
simply more tissue
in that area the quadrants aren't all
evenly sized and so
if you have more cells in the upper
outer quadrant that's where you're more
likely to find cancer
more cells means more cancer secondly
aluminium has had effects on cells in in
vitro studies some in vitro studies have
found that aluminium can
affect how estrogen receptors function
since the hormone estrogen has been
found to
increase the growth of breast cancer
this could be interpreted as evidence
that aluminium could be linked to breast
cancer aluminium has also been found to
damage dna
in cells but there are a lot of reasons
why these in vitro results don't
translate to how we use
antiperspirants on our skin for
aluminium to have effects on living
cells
it would have to be absorbed into your
skin at a high enough concentration
but the aluminium salts used in
antiperspirants don't absorb well into
skin
at all one study estimated that only
0.012
of the applied aluminium actually
absorbed into skin
most of our exposure to aluminium is
actually through food and it's estimated
that
the amount that you get from
antiperspirants versus the amount that
you get from food
it's about 2.5 percent so there really
isn't
a lot more aluminium in your body if
you're using an antiperspirant
the study that found the dna damage use
a really high concentration much higher
than you'd ever find in the body
in standard tests aluminium didn't have
any effect on cancer-causing mutations
another piece of evidence that gets
brought up is that aluminium
concentrations are higher in cancer
tissue
sometimes so some studies have found
that there's high aluminium in breast
cancer tissue
but other studies haven't found this
association in a really famous 2007
study there were 17 cancer patients
and they examined their breast cancer
tissue the aluminium was slightly high
in the outer region but they didn't
compare it with other parts of the body
or with people who didn't have breast
cancer
a 2011 study found higher aluminium in
nipple aspirate from women with breast
cancer than those without
a 2013 study looked at breast tissue
from people with breast cancer and they
didn't find any difference in aluminium
between the cancerous parts and the
non-cancerous parts
other scientists have also mentioned
that maybe breast cancer tissue just
collects more aluminium than other
tissue
this happens with some other substances
[Music]
so what do the human studies tell us the
best way to check if something causes
something in humans
is by looking at actual humans and the
more of them you have the better a 2002
study compared about 800 women with
breast cancer and 800 women without
and they found no link between breast
cancer risk and the use of
antiperspirants or deodorants
a 2003 study looked at questionnaires
from about 400 women with breast cancer
they found that women who used
antiperspirant and deodorant and shaved
their armpits
had an early age of diagnosis but some
other experts have pointed out some
problems with this study that would
limit how we can interpret the results
so for example we didn't look at how
often women without breast cancer use
these products
it could also just be saying that women
who use a lot of deodorant tend to be
younger
a 2006 study compared 54 women with
breast cancer and 50 without and they
didn't find that the women with breast
cancer used antiperspirants more
but they did find an association with
family history and the use of oral
contraceptives
so based on all this evidence it doesn't
seem like there's much of a link
between using antiperspirants with
aluminium and getting breast cancer
in humans with real world usage
[Music]
so why is the link between aluminium and
breast cancer so persistent
a number of cancer experts and
institutions have pointed out that it is
one particular research group who keeps
on researching the supposed link
between aluminium and breast cancer and
this is despite other scientists saying
that the link is pretty darn
unconvincing to the point where it's not
really worth investing
more resources into studying it this
group is the darba group you might
remember them as the people who started
the fearmongering about parabens based
on a really flawed study
their publications on aluminium keep on
emphasizing the invitro evidence
even though other studies strongly
indicate that these in vitro studies
don't translate to what actually happens
in humans it's really hard to be
convinced that there is a link between
aluminium and breast cancer there are
glaring issues with experimental design
over a lot of the studies that have
supposedly found a link
and if you study something enough you'll
inevitably find correlations that will
support your case
it's comforting to think that we can be
completely in control when it comes to
whether or not you get a disease
but the reality is a lot of the time
it's completely arbitrary or
out of our control it's impossible to
say what exactly caused a particular
case of cancer and it's usually not very
helpful either
a lot of people who have all of the risk
factors for cancer
never end up developing cancer i'm sure
we all know someone who smoked
continuously and never got lung cancer
but it can be useful to know the risk
factors so that you can improve your
chances against cancer
we know that breast cancer risk is
mostly associated with things that are
outside of our control
some of these are being female being
older being caucasian
having a family history of breast cancer
certain genetic factors
menstruating before age 12 and having
menopause after age 55
never having given birth being older
when you have your first child
and having dense breast tissue there are
also some environmental and lifestyle
factors that
are more within our control that are
also linked with breast cancer
sedentary lifestyle so not exercising
much poor diet drinking alcohol being
overweight
having ionizing radiation in the chest
area and having hormone replacement
therapy
these lifestyle factors are generally a
lot harder to change than just switching
your deodorant
so the narrative that such a simple
change can significantly help us against
something as scary as cancer
is really alluring even though the
scientific evidence just doesn't add up
and unfortunately this sort of
convenient lie can make
us a bit complacent and not act on the
things that we should
actually be acting on there are a few
other myths about why you shouldn't use
aluminium but here's the reality
not sweating is actually fine there's a
myth that because antiperspirants block
sweat then it stops
your body from getting rid of toxins but
your body mostly gets rid of toxins
through your kidneys they put into pee
or your liver which puts it into your
poop sweating plays an incredibly minor
role
the main function of sweat is just to
cool you down not to actually flush out
toxins
and you are sweating on the rest of your
body anyway there's no reason why the
toxins have to come out through your
armpits
sometimes this myth also involves some
talk of lymph nodes so
lymph nodes in your armpits are
supposedly important for clearing toxins
and the aluminium stops them from
working but the lymph nodes aren't
actually connected to your sweat glands
[Music]
so there are some valid reasons for
avoiding aluminium
if your skin is sensitive to aluminium
if they cause a rash then obviously you
shouldn't use it
if armpit sweat isn't a problem for you
then there's no reason for you to use it
if antiperspirants aren't working well
enough for you then maybe you should
look at other options like perhaps botox
injections
if you have incredibly poor kidney
function then you might want to avoid
extra aluminium you'll be doing this in
your diet as well
if you're about to go for a breast
screen then your doctor might tell you
to avoid using aluminium
but the reason for this is that it can
show up on images and make them
confusing to interpret it's not because
it's causing breast cancer so i hope you
like this video if you did give it a
thumbs up and you can subscribe to my
channel
leave me a comment letting me know what
other myths you want me to bust
you can follow me on instagram and check
out my blog for more on the science
behind beauty products
and i'll see you next time to nerd out
more
epidemiologic epidemiologic
epidemio logic